PRIVATE PHONE NUMBER AND KEEPS
IN TOUCH WITH THEM LONG AFTER.
TO KNOW JOE BIDEN IS TO KNOW
THAT LOVE WITHOUT PRETENSE,
SERVICE WITHOUT SELF-REGARD, AND
TO LIVE LIFE FULLY.
AS ONE OF HIS LONG-TIME
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE WHO
HAPPENED TO BE A REPUBLICAN ONCE
SAID, IF YOU CAN'T ADMIRE JOE
BIDEN AS A PERSON, YOU'VE GOT A
PROBLEM.
HE IS AS GOOD A MAN AS GOD EVER
CREATED.
SO, JOE, FOR YOUR FAITH IN YOUR
FELLOW AMERICANS, FOR YOUR LOVE
OF COUNTRY, AND FOR YOUR
LIFETIME OF SERVICE THAT WILL
ENDURE THROUGH THE GENERATIONS,
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE MILITARY AID
TO JOIN US ON STAGE.
FOR THE FINAL TIME AS PRESIDENT,
I AM PLEASED TO AWARD OUR
NATION'S HIGHEST CIVILIAN HONOR,
THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF
FREEDOM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND FOR THE FIRST AND ONLY TIME
IN MY PRESIDENCY, I WILL BESTOW
THIS MEDAL WITH AN ADDITIONAL
LEVEL OF VENERATION, AN HONOR MY
PREDECESSORS RESERVED FOR THREE
OTHERS, POPE JOHN PAUL II,
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN AND
COLONEL COLIN POWELL.
I AM PLEASE TODAY AWARD THIS
DISTINCTION TO MY BROTHER,
JOSEPH BIDEN, JR.
WILL THE AIDE PLEASE READ THE
CITATION?
>> VICE-PRESIDENT JOSEPH R.
BIDEN, JR., IN A CAREER OF
PUBLIC SERVICE EXTENDING NEARLY
HALF A CENTURY, VICE-PRESIDENT
JOSEPH R. BIDEN, JR., HAS LEFT
HIS MARK ON ALMOST EVERY PART OF
OUR NATION.
FIGHTING FOR A STRONGER MIDDLE
CLASS, A FAIRER JUDICIAL SYSTEM,
AND A SMARTER FOREIGN POLICY,
PROVIDING UNYIELDING SUPPORT FOR
OUR TROOPS, COMBATTING CRIME AND
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN, LEADING
OUR QUEST TO CURE CANCER, AND
SAFEGUARDING THE LAND MAMARK
RECOVERY FROM CORRUPTION.
WITH HIS CHARM, CANDOR, UNA
BARBED OPTIMISM AND DEEP AND
ABIDING PATRIOTISM, JOE BIDEN
HAS GARNERED THE RESPECT AND
ESTEEM OF COLLEAGUES OF BOTH
PARTIES.
AND THE FRIENDSHIP OF PEOPLE
ACROSS THE NATION AND AROUND THE
WORLD.
WHILE SUMMONING THE STRENGTH,
FAITH AND GRACE TO OVERCOME
GREAT PERSONAL TRAGEDY, THIS SON
OF SCRANTON, CLAY MONT, AND
WILMINGTON, HAS BECOME ONE OF
THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
VICE-PRESIDENTS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
AN ACCOLADE THAT NONETHELESS
RESTS FIRMLY BEHIND HIS LEGACY
AS HUSBAND, FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER, A GRATEFUL NATION
THANKS VICE-PRESIDENT JOSEPH R.
BIDEN, JR., FOR HIS LIFETIME OF
SERVICE ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> MR. PRESIDENT -- PLEASE,
PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
[ CHEERING AND APPLAUSE ]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE FIRED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
FOR THE PRESS, BRASHETTI IS MY
CHIEF OF STAFF.
I HAD NO INKLING.
I THOUGHT WE WERE COMING OVER,
MICHELLE, FOR YOU, JILL, AND
BARACK AND I TO -- A COUPLE OF
SENIOR STAFF TO TOAST ONE
ANOTHER AND SAY WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE JOURNEY IT'S BEEN.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU GOT RIGHT THE
PART ABOUT MY LEANING ON JILL.
I'VE ALSO LEANED ON YOU AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM.
I LOOK AROUND THE ROOM AND I SEE
GREAT FRIENDS LIKE TED COKAUFMA
WHO HAS SO MUCH WISDOM.
I LOOK AROUND, I'M SO STARTLED,
I SEE PEOPLE I DON'T EXPECT.
MADAM PRESIDENT, HOW ARE YOU?
I LOOK AT MY NEW BOSS OVER
THERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT YOU KNOW, I GET A LOT OF
CREDIT I DON'T DESERVE.
I STATE THE OBVIOUS.
BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS HAD SOMEBODY
TO LEAN ON, FROM BACK THAT TIME
IN 1972 WHEN THE ACCIDENT
HAPPENED, I LEANED ON -- AND I
MEAN THIS IN A LITERAL SENSE.
CHRIS KNOWS THIS, DODD KNOWS
THIS, MEL KNOWS THIS, TED KNOWS
THIS.
I LEANED ON MY SONS BO AND
HUNTER.
AND I CONTINUE TO LEAN ON HUNTER
WHO CONTINUES TO, IN A BIZARRE
KIND OF WAY, RAISE ME.
I MEAN, I'VE LEANED ON THEM.
YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT, YOU
OBSERVED EARLY ON THAT WHEN
EITHER ONE OF MY BOYS WOULD WALK
IN THE ROOM, THEY'D WALK UP AND
SAY, DAD, WHAT CAN I GET YOU?
DAD, WHAT DO YOU NEED?
AND THEN JILL CAME ALONG AND SHE
SAVED OUR LIFE.
SHE -- NO MAN DESERVES ONE GREAT
LOVE, LET ALONE TWO.
AND -- BUT EVERYBODY KNOWS HERE
I AM JILL'S HUSBAND.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT I LOVE HER
MORE THAN SHE LOVES ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WITH GOOD REASON.
AND SHE GAINED THE MOST PRECIOUS
GIFT, THE LOVE OF MY LIFE, THE
LIFE OF MY LOVE, MY DAUGHTER
ASHLEY.
AND I CONTINUE TO LEAN ON THE
FAMILY.
PRESIDENT, YOU KIDDED ME ONCE.
YOU HEARD THAT IN PREPARATION
FOR THE TWO DEBATES,
VICE-PRESIDENTIAL DEBATES I HAD,
I ONLY HAD TWO, THAT BO AND
HUNTER WOULD BE THE LAST PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM.
BO WOULD SAY, LOOK AT ME, DAD,
LOOK AT ME.
REMEMBER, REMEMBER HOME BASE,
REMEMBER.
SO, AND THE SECRET SERVICE CAN
TELL YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, THAT BO
AND HUNT AND ASHLEY CONTINUE TO
HAVE TO CORRAL ME.
AT THE NATIONAL PARKS I WAS
CLIMBING ON TOP OF THE BRIDGE TO
JUMP OFF THE BRIDGE WITH A BUNCH
OF YOUNG KIDS.
AND I HEAR MY SONS YELLING, DAD,
GET DOWN.
NOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND I JUST STARTED LAUGHING SO
HARDY COULDN'T STOP.
I SAID, WAYS GOING TO DO A FLIP
OR FULL GAINER.
DAD, THE SECRET SERVICE DOESN'T
WANT YOU UP THERE, DAD.
LOOK AT ME, DAD.
SO, WE'VE NEVER FIGURED OUT WHO
THE FATHER IS IN THIS FAMILY.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW THAT
WITH GOOD REASON THERE IS NO
POWER IN THE VICE-PRESIDENCY.
I DID FOR NANCY PELOSI'S
DAUGHTER, THE READING OF THE
CONSTITUTION, YOU PROBABLY DID
ONE FOR HER, THEY HAD ME READ
THE PROVISIONS OF THE
VICE-PRESIDENCY IN THE
CONSTITUTION, AND THERE IS NO
INHERENT POWER, NOR SHOULD THERE
BE.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE, YOU
HAVE MORE THAN KEPT YOUR
COMMITMENT TO ME BY SAYING THAT
YOU WANTED ME TO HELP GOVERN.
PRESIDENT'S LINE OFTEN, PEOPLE
DON'T HEAR IT OFTEN, BUT SOMEONE
WOULD SAY, CAN YOU GET JOE TO DO
SUCH AND SUCH?
YOU SAID, I DON'T DO HIS
SCHEDULE AND HE DOESN'T DO MINE.
EVERY SINGLE THING YOU'VE ASKED
ME TO DO, MR. PRESIDENT, YOU
HAVE TRUSTED ME TO DO.
AND THAT IS A REMARKABLE THING.
I DON'T THINK, ACCORDING TO -- I
SEE THE PRESIDENT OF GEORGETOWN
HERE AS WELL.
I DON'T THINK ACCORDING TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL, VICE-PRESIDENTIAL
SCHOLARS THAT KIND OF
RELATIONSHIP HAS EXISTED -- I
MEAN, FOR REAL.
IT'S ALL YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
IT'S ALL YOU.
THE REASON WHY WHEN YOU SENT ME
AROUND THE WORLD, NOTHING GOOD,
AS MY MOM WOULD SAY, GETS MISSED
BETWEEN THE CUP AND A LIP
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHEN I SPEAK I
SPEAK TRUE.
IT'S BEEN EASY, MR. PRESIDENT,
BECAUSE WE NOT ONLY HAVE THE
SAME POLITICAL PHILOSOPHY AND
IDEOLOGY.
I TELL EVERYBODY, I'VE TOLD THEM
FROM THE BEGINNING AND I'M NOT
SAYING THIS TO RECIPROCATE.
I'VE NEVER KNOWN A PRESIDENT,
AND FEW PEOPLE I'VE EVER MET MY
WHOLE LIFE, I CAN COUNT ON LESS
THAN ONE HAND, WHO HAVE HAD THE
INTEGRITY AND DECENCY AND THE
SENSE OF OTHER PEOPLE'S NEEDS
LIKE YOU DO.
I KNOW YOU'RE UPSET WHEN I TOLD
THE STORY ABOUT WHEN HUNT AND I
WERE WORRIED THAT BO WOULD HAVE
TO -- THEY WOULD, AS A MATTER OF
HONOR, DECIDE TO STEP DOWN AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHILE HE WAS
FIGHTING HIS BATTLE BECAUSE HE
HAD APHASIA.
HE WAS LOSING HIS ABILITY TO
SPEAK.
AND HE DIDN'T WANT TO EVER BE IN
A POSITION WHERE TO HIM
EVERYTHING WAS ABOUT DUTY AND
HONOR.
AND I SAID -- AND HE MAY RESIGN,
I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST HAVE A FEELING HE MAY.
HUNT AND I TALKED ABOUT THIS.
HE SAID, HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY
OTHER INCOME, BUT WE'RE ALL
RIGHT BECAUSE HUNT'S THERE AND I
CAN SELL THE HOUSE.
WE WERE HAVING A PRIVATE LUNCH
LIKE WE DO ONCE A WEEK.
AND THIS MAN GOT UP, CAME OVER,
GRABBED ME BY THE SHOULDERS, AND
LOOKED ME IN THE EYE AND SAID,
DON'T YOU SELL THAT HOUSE.
YOU LOVE THAT HOUSE.
I SAID, IT'S NO BIG DEAL,
MR. PRESIDENT.
HE SAID, I'LL GIVE YOU THE
MONEY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE MONEY.
PROMISE ME.
YOU WON'T SELL THAT HOUSE.
I REMEMBER WHEN ASHLEY,
MR. PRESIDENT, WE WERE IN THE
OVAL AND ASHLEY WAS IN THE
ELEVATOR, AND THE ELEVATOR
PLUMMETED -- SHE WAS WITH A
GROUP OF PEOPLE, I FORGET WHICH
BUILDING IN PHILADELPHIA, IT
PLUMMETED TO THE GROUND.
AND IMMEDIATELY THE SERVICE WAS
WORRIED THAT SHE MAY HAVE BEEN
BADLY HURT.
AND I GOT UP TO TAKE THE CALL
AND YOU DIDN'T LET UP UNTIL YOU
MADE SURE YOUR SERVICE FOLLOWED
THROUGH AND MADE SURE EVERYTHING
WAS ALL RIGHT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, MR. PRESIDENT,
YOU KNOW, WE KID ABOUT BOTH
ABOUT MARRYING UP, WE BOTH DID
THAT KIND OF THING.
BUT THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER
IS -- I SAID THIS TO MICHELLE
LAST NIGHT -- MICHELLE IS THE
FINEST FIRST LADY, IN MY VIEW,
THAT HAS EVER SERVED IN THE
OFFICE.
THERE'S ANOTHER GREAT FIRST
LADIES, BUT I GENERALLY MEAN IT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WHEN I GOT TO MEET MICHELLE'S
BROTHER AND HE TOLD ME ABOUT HOW
YOU GUYS WERE RAISED AND I GOT
TO KNOW AND LOVE YOUR MOM, IF
YOUR MOM WERE 15 YEARS OLDER,
SHE COULD HAVE BEEN MY MOM,
LITERALLY.
THE WAY YOU WERE RAISED, THE WAY
WE WERE RAISED, IT WASN'T ANY
DIFFERENCE.
AND I KNEW THAT THIS DECISION TO
JOIN YOU, WHICH IS THE GREATEST
HONOR IN MY LIFE, WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION ON THE NIGHT WE HAD TO
GO AND ACCEPT THE NOMINATION,
THE FORMAL -- TO BE NOMINATED AT
THE CONVENTION.
AND FINNEGAN WHO IS NOW
18-YEAR-OLD, WAS TEN YEARS OLD.
SHE CAME TO ME AND SHE SAID,
POP, IS IT OKAY IF THE ROOM THAT
WE'RE IN, FINNEGAN, MAZY AND
NAOMI, THAT WE HAVE THE BEDS
TAKEN OUT?
AND I SAID, WHY?
SHE SAID, MAYBE THE OBAMA GIRLS
AND YOUR BROTHER'S CHILDREN,
MAYBE THEY CAN COME DOWN AND WE
CAN ALL SLEEP TOGETHER IN
SLEEPING BAGS.
AND I GIVE YOU MY WORD AS A
BIDEN, I KNEW WHEN I LEFT TO GO
TO THE CONVENTION, OPEN THAT
DOOR AND SAW THEM CUDDLED
TOGETHER, I KNEW THIS WAS THE
RIGHT DECISION.
I KNEW IT WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION.
I REALLY DID.
BECAUSE, MR. PRESIDENT, THE SAME
VALUE SET, THE SAME VALUE SET --
FOLKS, YOU KNOW, I JOKE WITH MY
STAFF THAT I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY
PAY THEM ANYTHING BECAUSE THEY
GET TO ADVISE ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT.
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF DELAWARE WHERE MY
HEART RESIDES IN DELAWARE, THEY
CAN TELL YOU, I GET TO GIVE
ADVICE.
I GET TO BE THE LAST GUY IN THE
ROOM AND GIVE YOU ADVICE ON THE
MOST DIFFICULT DECISIONS ANYONE
HAS TO MAKE IN THE WHOLE WORLD.
BUT I GET TO WALK OUT AND YOU
MAKE IT ALL BY YOURSELF, ALL BY
YOURSELF.
HA
HARRY TRUMAN WAS RIGHT ABOUT THE
BUCK STOPPING AT THE DESK.
AND I'VE NEVER, NEVER, NEVER,
NEVER, NEVER ONCE DOUBTED ON
THESE LIFE AND DEATH DECISIONS,
I NEVER ONCE DOUBTED THAT YOUR
JUDGMENT WAS FLAWED, NOT ONCE,
NOT ONCE.
WE'VE DISAGREED AND ARGUED AND
WE'VE RAISED OUR VOICES AT ONE
ANOTHER.
WE MADE A DEAL WE WOULD BE
COMPLETELY OPEN LIKE BROTHERS
WITH ONE ANOTHER.
BUT, MR. PRESIDENT, I'VE WATCHED
YOU UNDER INTENSE FIRE.
I WILL VENTURE TO SAY THAT NO
PRESIDENT IN HISTORY HAS HAD AS
MANY NOVEL CRISES LAND ON HIS
DESK IN ALL OF HISTORY.
THE CIVIL WAR WAS WORSE, WORLD
WAR II WAS WORSE.
BUT, MR. PRESIDENT, ALMOST EVERY
ONE OF THE CRISES YOU FACED WAS
A CASE OF FIRST INSTANCE, CASE
OF FIRST INSTANCE.
AND I WATCHED THAT PRODIGIOUS
MIND AND HEART AS BIG AS YOUR
HEAD, I'VE WATCHED YOU.
I'VE WATCHED HOW YOU'VE ACTED.
WHEN YOU SEE A WOMAN OR MAN
UNDER INTENSE PRESSURE, YOU GET
A MEASURE AND YOU KNOW THAT,
MICHELLE, AND YOUR DAUGHTERS
KNOW IT AS WELL.
THIS IS A REMARKABLE MAN.
AND I JUST HOPE THAT THE
ASTERISK IN HISTORY THAT IS
ATTACHED TO MY NAME WHEN THEY
TALK ABOUT THIS PRESIDENCY IS
THAT I CAN SAY I WAS PART OF,
PART OF THE JOURNEY OF A
REMARKABLE MAN WHO DID
REMARKABLE THINGS FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
REMARKABLE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
YOU KNOW I CAN'T LET A COMMENT
GO BY WITHOUT QUOTING AN IRISH
POET.
[ LAUGHTER ]
JILL AND I TALK ABOUT WHY YOU
ARE ABLE TO DEVELOP THE WAY YOU
DEVELOPED AND WITH THE HEART YOU
HAVE.
MICHELLE AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
IT.
I'VE CONFIDED IN MICHELLE, I'VE
GONE TO HER FOR ADVICE.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS MAN.
YOU'VE GIVEN ME INSIGHT.
AND I THINK IT'S BECAUSE,
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU GAVE ME
CREDIT FOR HAVING UNDERSTANDING
OTHER PEOPLE'S MISERY AND
SUFFERING.
MR. PRESIDENT, THERE'S NOT ONE
SI
SINGLE SOLITARY OUNCE OF
ENTITLEMENT IN YOU OR MICHELLE
OR YOUR BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS.
YOU GIRLS ARE INCREDIBLE.
YOU REALLY ARE.
IT'S NOT HYPERBOLE, YOU REALLY
ARE.
NOT ONE OUNCE OF ENTITLEMENT.
AND SHAMUS HANEY, ONE OF THOSE
POETS SAID --
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHEN YOU CAN FIND SOMEONE WHO
SAYS IT BETTER, USE IT.
HE SAID, YOU CARRIED YOUR OWN
BURDEN, AND VERY SOON YOUR
SYMPTOMS OF CREEPING PRIVILEGE
DISAPPEARED.
YOU CARRIED YOUR OWN BURDENS AND
VERY SOON YOUR CREEPING SYMPTOMS
OF PRIVILEGE DISAPPEARED.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE
SOMETIMES BEEN LIKE A LONE WOLF,
BUT YOU CARRIED YOURSELF IN A
WAY THAT IS PRETTY REMARKABLE.
THE HISTORY OF THE JOURNEY, YOUR
JOURNEY, IS SOMETHING PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO WRITE ABOUT A LONG
TIME.
AND I'M NOT BEING SOLICITOUS
WHEN I SAY THIS.
AND YOU ARE SO FORTUNATE, BOTH
OF YOU, TO HAVE FOUND EACH OTHER
BECAUSE ALL THAT GROUNDING, ALL
THAT THAT YOU HAVE MADE THIS GUY
TOTALLY WHOLE.
IT'S PRETTY AMAZING.
MR. PRESIDENT, THIS HONOR IS NOT
ONLY WELL BEYOND WHAT I DESERVE,
BUT IT'S A REFLECTION OF THE
EXTENT AND GENEROSITY OF YOUR
SPIRIT.
I DON'T DESERVE THIS.
BUT I KNOW IT CAME FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S HEART.
THERE IS A TALMUDIC SAYING THAT
SAYS, WHAT COMES FROM THE HEART
AND IS THE HEART.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE CREEPED
INTO OUR HEART, YOU AND YOUR
WHOLE FAMILY, INCLUDING MOM, AND
YOU OCCUPY IT.
IT'S AN AMAZING THING THAT
HAPPENED.
I KNEW HOW SMART YOU WERE.
I KNEW HOW HONORABLE YOU WERE.
I KNEW HOW DECENT YOU WERE FROM
THE COUPLE YEARS YOU WORKED IN
THE SENATE.
AND I KNEW WHAT YOU WERE CAPABLE
OF.
BUT I NEVER FULLY EXPECTED THAT
YOU'D OCCUPY THE BIDENS' HEART
FROM HUNTER, ASHLEY, MY SISTER,
ALL OF US, ALL OF US.
AND, MR. PRESIDENT, I'M INDEBTED
TO YOU.
I'M INDEBTED TO YOUR FRIENDSHIP.
I'M INDEBTED TO YOUR FAMILY.
AND AS I'LL TELL YOU ON A
HUMOROUS NOTE, WE'RE HAVING
LUNCH, LUNCHES, MOSTLY --
WHATEVER IS IN OUR MINDS.
WE TALK ABOUT FAMILY AN AWFUL
LOT.
AND ABOUT SIX MONTHS IN,
PRESIDENT LOOKS AT ME AND HE
SAID, YOU KNOW, JOE?
YOU KNOW WHAT SURPRISED ME?
HOW WE'VE BECOME SUCH GOOD
FRIENDS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND I SAID, SURPRISED YOU?
BUT THAT IS CANDID OBAMA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND IT'S REAL.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW AS LONG
AS THERE IS BREATH IN ME, I'LL
BE THERE FOR YOU, MY FAMILY WILL
BE THERE.
I KNOW IT IS RECIPROCAL.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL SO
VERY, VERY, VERY MUCH, ALL OF
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]